now the goal of this unit will be for
you to write a physics engine class to
manage the interaction of box2d to your
game engine now first things first is
that will need to create a new physics
engine class and create a global
instance variable for it now the core of
box2d simulation is a variable type
called world which is used as the main
handle to the rest the api's as such we
need to add a create function to our
class and inside here create a new
instance of the world object note that
typically the world constructor takes a
vector that represents the gravity of
the world since now we're a top-down
game we really don't need a 2d gravity
vector so we're just going to leave this
as 0 0 for now now the second variable
in the constructor is a boolean which
tells box2d if an object is allowed to
sleep or not given some time threshold
tolerance for the computation now for
our purposes we don't want to let object
sleep so we set this to false the core
of box2d simulation is a variable type
called world now this is going to be
used as the main handle to the rest of
the API so we're going to use as such we
need to add a create function to our
class and inside of there create an
instance of the world object so to move
on go ahead and create an instance of
the world object passing in a vector and
a boolean value